let's continue on the liar train cringe
Jean-Pierre who took over for Jan saki
she is now the White House Press
Secretary this woman should be studied
by scientists she can't say anything
truth you thought saki couldn't say
anything true every now and again saki
would leak a little truth accidentally
remember saki oh we uh we do flag posts
for Facebook she didn't really mean to
say it but she kind of leaked it out
this one Karin jump here she is so in
over her head she was obviously a
diversity hire she's a black lesbian I
don't care about her skin color or her
sexuality but that's why they hired her
it's as simple as that here she is 100
percent lying about Florida's
don't say good
I also want to say a word about the
decision yesterday made by the Florida
Board of Education to expand the state's
dystopian don't say gay law
as this measure takes effect it will
prohibit all students up to seniors in
high school from learning about our
learning about or discussing lgbtqi plus
people in the classrooms teachers in
Florida have already faced the
devastating consequences of the existing
law under threat of having their
licenses revoked gay teachers have been
forced to take down pictures of their
spouses from their desks and censor
their classroom materials
censoring our classes is not how public
education is supposed to work in a free
country
conservative politicians love to
complain about the so-called cancel
culture
all while threatening teachers with
losing their jobs if they teach
something that the Maga extremists don't
agree with
that help you lying sack of ugh these
people it's only Monday okay let's just
go through it there is no assault on
lgbtqi people here in Florida please
show me what teachers have been fired
for doing any of these things it is
simply not true this idea that a teacher
can't have a picture of their spouse or
boyfriend or girlfriend on their desk
completely not true actually Community
notes which is Twitter's new
crowd-sourced uh fact-checking system
they completely blew her apart on this
it's completely not true there's
obviously nothing in the bill for that
you cannot talk about sex and gender and
sexuality outside of the disciplines say
health class where it should be taught
you're it's not that a social studies
class can't when it's teaching about
Civics talk about the Supreme Court
ruling on gay marriage it's an absolute
abject lie uh foreign
[Music]